[Music]
ha that's much better
let's start with the iPhone 7 the iPhone
is rated ip67 it should withstand 1
meter of water for 30 minutes that means
your phone will survive an accidental
dunk in the pool or a splash but you
shouldn't do this and I'm not even sure
why you'd want to water makes the
touchscreen go wonky and it's hard to
get cellular or Wi-Fi service for
texting friends but there is a trick hit
the record button before you go down and
you can do or you can press the volume
up button on the side of the iPhone to
snap a photo still proceed with caution
both iPhones were fine after swimming
with them for nearly an hour but Apple
says very clearly liquid damage not
covered under warranty there's an
exception if you have Apple care but a
dead phone is never fun with
one-one-one-one there's a special water
button that locks the screen so water
doesn't mistakenly launch apps it can
track your laps and the distance you
swam the coolest thing because there's
this speaker hole when you get out you
need to eject the water from it by
spinning the digital crown boom water
eject it
[Music]